[Music]
[Music]
University of Kentucky who you know now
here you name it ringing no bells but
who are you know from out here you name
me bring in no bells but who you know
from out here you name a ringing no
bells but we be posted out here we slang
is hanging themselves but not all in the
mail got it shipped out from Cali doe me
me under scale make it move like a rally
horse rolling down the window blowing
smoke with my bad little look inside my
cup that's my drink water smacking me
folk we got all that party or what you
asking folk and I never tell even if
it's the last result addicted to lame
every Yahoo we pass a foe she got it
crush some stairs best believe I'm a
snatch it through you know from ouchie
your name ain't ringing no bells what
who you know from ouchie your name ain't
ringing no bells boy who you
who you know tattoos on the body I gotta
Justin Jionni nighttime sloppy top in
the morning she busts for lytics rocks
all in the Sox back then when I was on
the Charlie trying to push our move up
to God hey you ain't gotta ask cuz you
know my section rowdy I ain't got a
blast cuz you know my little Rami
running from the past man I know that
she got cloudy cash all in the stash
where we load ducking kappa who you know
from how hair you name a ringing no
bells boy who you know from my you name
a ringing no bells boy